the late american defense secretary
donald rumsfeld famously said that there
were three types of knowledge in war
known knowns
known unknowns and unknown unknowns that
is things that we know that we know
things that we don't know
and things that we don't even know
that we don't know
but there is a fourth type
of war knowledge
known
unknowns that is things we think we know
that in fact we do not know
and when it comes to the war in ukraine
it is that fourth kind of knowledge that
we are all full of everyone knows for
instance about the ghost of kiev the ace
fighter pilot who shot down five maybe
even seven russian fighter jets on just
the first day of fighting we know about
him because we read about him on social
media we even saw videos of his heroics
in the sky
except we didn't
the video isn't real
the airplane isn't even real
it's a cartoon from a digital combat
video game
everyone knows for instance
that ukrainian president volodymir
zelensky is not only refusing to flee or
surrender but is actually fighting on
the front lines we know this because
we've all seen the photos of him wearing
combat fatigues gun in tote
except
the photo isn't from last week it's
actually from months ago and a long way
from kiev here we go reuters fact check
everyone knows
about the 13 brave sailors guarding
snake island who refused to back down to
a russian ship whose final words to the
russians were
go f yourself before all 13 were killed
we know this because we saw the video
this is the russian worship comes up
this is the russian warship i repeat
i suggest you surrender your weapons and
capitulate otherwise i will open fire
do you copy okay and then so it's just
you're just seeing this on the island
and you're hearing this audio ukrainian
said this is it
should i tell him to go f himself
just in case
turns up the volume
russian warship
go f yourself
and then
we were told they were all killed but
what a way to go out we saw that happen
except we didn't
it turns out the sailors happily were
probably not killed but captured as even
the ukrainian foreign ministry now
admits
none of this is to take away from the
bravery of the ukrainians those sailors
there they seem like pretty tough dudes
okay regardless of whether they were
killed or captured
the ukrainian servicemen the civilians
and president zielinski himself are all
demonstrating immense bravery but most
of the stories you're hearing right now
about this war seem incredible
precisely because they are not credible
they are the product of dueling
propaganda machines with both sides
going into overdrive to spin the best
yarns to help their side
this war is unlike anything we've seen
in my lifetime it occurred to me a
couple of nights ago
that this is the first major war in my
lifetime to take place between civilized
nations
and it's all the more frightening
because our political elite in the west
did not believe it could actually happen
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from not a cat
who quoting john kerry says hey please
invade with hybrid electric tanks thank
you yes that's true that'll that'll help
turn things around that way we won't get
distracted by the bloodshed and the
tanks and the missiles and the air
strikes distracted from the really
important issue that is the sun monster
that's that's what we've got to do we
gotta we gotta really
focus on especially energy policy here
well when you wanna focus on energy
policy at home i strongly recommend you
check out get upside gas prices are
through the roof that's why you need to
download the free get upside app and use
code knowles what will that get you that
will save you
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time you fill up how through cash back
there is no catch there are no hoops you
got to jump through you just download
the free get upside app in the app store
or google play right now you use promo
code knowles you get 25 cents per gallon
or more on your first fill up cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore gas is about to go up even
higher than it already has been in
recent months you can earn up to 30
percent cash back not just at gas
stations but at grocery stores
restaurants food delivery too
you cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app use promo code
knowles know w-l-e-s just free money get
25 cents per gallon or more cash back on
your first tank promo code knowles
one day after the fighting started in
ukraine
there were people friends of mine here
at the daily wire outside the daily wire
they said oh my gosh michael did you
hear about the ghost of kiev i said what
yeah i saw it trending what's the ghost
of oh michael it's unbelievable there's
this ace fighter pilot no one knows who
he is and he's just shooting down
russian fighter jets left and right they
haven't seen this kind of thing since
world war ii they haven't seen this
thing in 70 years probably i said oh
yeah and how do you know about the ghost
of kiev i said well we saw him trending
on twitter
oh twitter that thing that is completely
controlled by a handful of extremely
ideological people that totally
manipulated and why else do you believe
well we saw this video man it's like
something out of hollywood oh something
out of hollywood you say
huh
maybe
maybe and i don't want to sound like a
tinfoil hat guy here maybe it's
completely fake
like most of what the establishment
tells us maybe it's just completely made
up in some sound stage in hollywood or
more likely on a hard drive
in in hollywood of course there's a ton
of propaganda there's propaganda in
every war
we happen to be living in an age of
extremely accelerated extremely
heightened propaganda because of of how
advanced our technology has become just
think about how easy it is to make a
deep fake think about how easy it is to
use photoshop now place the most
powerful governments on earth in charge
of that technology
and and
recognize that they've also got access
to the widest communications
distribution platform ever known to man
that can be highly manipulated without
you even realizing it and then you see
propaganda taken to brand new heights
this is this is not
a war between say a superpower on one
hand and uh illiterate goat herders on
the other this is a war between
civilized nations okay civilized nations
who are known but well it's it's a war
technically between russia and ukraine
but it's really a proxy battle between
russia and the west so you're seeing a
kind of replay of the cold war here two
two entities very well known for their
extremely sophisticated propaganda
especially the russians
i'm not saying i'm not saying
necessarily
that everything you think you know about
this war is false i'm not what i am
saying is that there is absolutely no
reason to believe that any of the things
you think you know about this war
are true we just we just don't know we
just don't know we are in the midst
obviously the ukrainians are in the
midst of a real
guns firepower war the rest of the world
is in the midst of a very intense
propaganda war now this isn't to say
there's no genuine heroism there's a
story
it appears to be a very a real story of
of a hero sailor
vitali shakun velodemirovic i'm sure i'm
butchering the the pronunciation
this was a ukrainian sailor who saw that
the russians were about to cross a
bridge from russian occupied crimea to
mainland ukraine
so he runs out on the bridge onto the
bridge he realizes that that he's not
going to be able to get off if he wants
to destroy the bridge and he blows
himself up
now this that story appears to be true
it's very very impressive that's genuine
heroism
it's very hard to parse though the the
real heroism from the made-up propaganda
there's a parliament mender a member in
ukraine right now
uh so this woman in ukraine uh tweets
out quote i learn to use kalashnikov and
prepare to bear arms it sounds surreal
as just a few days ago it would never
come to my mind our women will protect
our soil the same way as our men go
ukraine
now it seems like she's staying in
ukraine i don't think she's fled
seems that she's got a kalashnikov in
her hand
this is one of i guess it's true i guess
it's real
it's hard to tell a little bit more of a
margin call and then some things we just
can't possibly know the ukrainians are
claiming that they have killed thousands
of russian fighters the ukrainian
government is claiming that russia has
suffered about 3 000 troop casualties
and and
lost 516 kinds of various military
vehicles 80 tanks 10 airplanes seven
helicopters that was just by friday i'm
sure they're claiming much higher
numbers now
is that true i don't know
we just don't know
we don't
really know
what is going on
in ukraine and yet we're all glued to it
and we are following this and we're
very wrapped up in the outcome obviously
and we're you know vladimir putin
appears to be implying that he's willing
to use nuclear weapons for goodness
sakes this war feels very different than
other wars that we've had at least in my
lifetime there have been a lot of wars
in my lifetime this one feels totally
different why
what occurs i got into a lot of trouble
for saying this i don't i don't even i
did not expect to get into a ton of
trouble for saying this but as usual
when you say something that is obviously
true those are the tweets that get you
into trouble
and so what i said the other night was
this is the first
major war
in my lifetime to take place between
civilized nations there have been other
wars
okay there have been wars
there was the breakup of yugoslavia
there were those wars was that a mate i
wouldn't call those major wars
there was kosovo i remember kosovo
vividly from the 90s would you would you
call that a major war though all of the
world is holding their breath probably
not there were obviously the middle
eastern wars
but would
would you would you say please forgive
me i know i'm not supposed to say this
would you really say that moammar
gaddafi's libya
is the height of civilization
uh i don't think so bashar assad syria
you think that's really that's it you
think of renaissance rome and bashar
assad syria yes civilization ain't it
great no i don't think so some people
responding a lot of very angry blue
checks were responding to my observation
and they said michael you idiot don't
you know that iraq is the birthplace of
civilization many thousands of years ago
iraq was a civilization yeah it's been a
while hasn't it
hasn't it do you are you do you think
now today or even during saddam
hussein's reign you're just going to go
to to iraq for a lovely getaway part of
the grand tour we're going to go to all
the wonderful civilized salon
discussions in in saddam hussein's iraq
i don't think so
okay it's so disingenuous this war
really is
different
you know the only thing worse than
democrats state of the union address is
the predictably tepid official gop
response well on tuesday night 15
minutes following president biden's
remarks before a joint session of
congress ben shapiro will offer a real
reaction one based in fact free from
focus group testing and oversight by
republican party leadership put simply
ben will destroy
joe biden the state of the union with
facts and logic join me ben jeremy
boring matt walsh and andrew clavin
tomorrow night at 8 15 eastern 7 15
central on daley wires youtube channel
ben's formal response will be airing as
soon as biden's address ends on the same
channel so make sure that you tune in
you know
when you tune in on youtube it's
actually completely free that's a price
you can afford and when you want really
good prices i strongly recommend you
check out priceline head on over to
priceline.com right now it feels like
we're all getting less these days less
social interaction less sunlight less
steps in less time in the office
while that last one might not be so bad
aren't you ready for more don't you want
more stuff since 1998 priceline has been
the best way for travelers to book the
trip they want at the price they can
afford priceline saves consumers more
than one
billion dollars every year billion with
a b so their customers never have to
miss the moments that matter with
priceline you can save up to 60 on your
favorite hotels you can also get
exclusive deals on rental cars and
flights when you save more you can do
more more walks on the beach more
talking to strangers more fun in the sun
no matter where you travel
still
less being in the office there are a few
things that feel as good as knowing that
you saved money with the discounts
priceline offers you get that feeling a
lot because when you save more you can
enjoy more and do more priceline every
trip is a big deal so when you're ready
to book at priceline.com
for the best deals that will help you
get more out of it
this war
is different
this war is different
when i said that this is the first major
war between civilized nations in my
lifetime i chose those words carefully
and all of these liberals got so angry i
mean there have been thousands and
thousands of responses all sorts of blue
checks and one thing i notice
about all of the responses to my
observation is they're really angry and
they call me all sorts of names and they
use all sorts of nasty language and none
of them have examples of of
wars that prove me wrong
they'll say they'll say what about the
nagor what about the 2020 and 2021
nagorno-karabakh conflict
what what are you talking about
well what about what about the war in
afghanistan i said civilized
well what about this or that there's
major war
between civilized nations
i'm i'm sorry if it hurts your feelings
to point out that libya is not a
particularly civilized place i'm sorry
if it hurts your feelings to point out
that a battle between saudi arabia and
yemen does not match all of those
criteria but this is a little different
we're talking about reality you've got a
nuclear former superpower
conquering
its neighbor
ukraine
a state with a long history of
civilization that's a little bit
different
okay i'm not even making the when i when
i made this observation it wasn't some
dunk on middle eastern tin pot
dictatorships it wasn't it it wasn't to
say oh how wonderful russia is or
ukraine is even or western europe for
that matter it was to point out that
this is a different kind of war that's
why we're treating it differently and
the propaganda propaganda's really
turned up a level because of that
civilization because they're really
really good at it they're better at it
than yemen is okay and it's even it's
even
more crucial
to how we view this war because the
liberals didn't think this could happen
right this was the argument
the after the cold war we've reached the
end of history we're liberalism won
relatively free markets won globalism
won free trade among nations at one
we're going to just slowly expand that
into a new world order and i'm not this
is not a tin foil hat phrase this is a
phrase used by the president of the
united states by
state department officials we're gonna
have a kind of order of the nations
we've got one hegemonic superpower
that's the united states we're all going
to trade we're all going to get along
and there's not going to be any more
wars certainly no more wars between the
civilized nations except there are
except it's happening but putin he's not
supposed to invade ukraine yeah well he
did
so what are you going to do about it the
thing that you said wasn't going to
happen that
all of us conservatives said very likely
would happen very much could happen that
thing did happen so jen saki so white
house can you just answer me a simple
question
what policies have you
used with regard to the ukraine conflict
what policies have you put in place that
have worked
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions are
going to take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked uh what the
president has done is he has built a
global coalition uh to stand up in the
face of president putin and president
putin's aggression and invasion of
ukraine what he has done is he has
rallied the world our eu european
partners even at cost to them in some
capacities to put in place uh
significant sanctions historic sanctions
that would have a a a enormous impact on
the russian financial sector it is
president putin's choice to go to war
and invade ukraine that is what he has
done
so nothing you got nothing okay
you you knew that jen saki had nothing
the moment that peter ducey finished
asking the question and she said hey
wait hold on what worked what do you
mean what worked like she's stalling
like kids do in class you know seventh
grade english class hey johnny what what
happened in chapter three
uh chapter three
do you want me to answer the question
about you yes that's what i asked you
chapter three huh um
well let me get let me give you a little
lesson about literature that's what
she's saying let me give you a little
lesson about diplomacy no i don't need a
lesson about diplomacy i don't need
international relations 101 just cite
the policy that's worked well
um
well hey forget about the policies that
we've already tried that didn't work uh
we're gonna put some sanctions on russia
oh
oh you're gonna put sanctions on russia
the thing that trump did that then biden
took away
but okay what kind of sanctions because
trump put sanctions on russian energy
trump stopped the
nordstrom 2 pipeline which is
if any
specific
individual event
is at the heart of this war right now
between russia and ukraine it would be
this pipeline because the minute that
vladimir putin gets to the green light
on his pipeline he gets to invade
ukraine because he doesn't need to rely
on ukraine to ship his oil from russia
to europe
so what about that oh right joe biden
gave the green light to the pipeline
which was essentially rolling out the
red carpet for vladimir putin to invade
ukraine what are you doing now oh you're
putting sanctions on russia except
you're not sanctioning the russian
energy industry which is the only thing
that matters in russia
that this news had started to break on
friday
okay we're going to have sanctions on
all the other industries in russia
russia and the haberdashers are going to
be in trouble
the people who make those stacking dolls
in russia oh boy they're going to have a
bad christmas they're going to have
trouble heating their homes but they're
not going to have too much trouble
because the russian oil industry is
going to be just fine
the russian gas industry is going to be
just fine nothing they've done nothing
that has worked and i was trying to
figure out why
why we know that the bidens are in the
pocket of ukraine let's
not forget speaking of the energy
industry joe biden's son hunter had a
no-show job in ukraine because ukraine
is also a corrupt oligarchy just like
russia and and he had this no-show job
where he was being paid hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars to do
absolutely nothing for the expertise in
ukrainian oil that he obviously does not
possess
so why by the biden family has
some interest in ukraine
why
why do they seem to be so incoherent in
their policy because they don't
have any direction they didn't think
this war was pot the liberal
establishment did not believe this war
would really happen
it it breaks their view of the world
that russia would invade another country
and so they don't know what to do when
it happens and they go one way and they
go the other and they keep vacillating
back and forth and they're what they're
really trying to do is just pretend that
it's not happening but it is happening
and it's happening because of specific
policies and incentives you left in
place
what can joe biden do
not very much if you ask him
let me pull this out for you
there you go
you got it but
okay
say presidents can't do much
thank you thank you
uh-huh i dropped my speech where's my
hahaha
can't we can't presidents can't do much
some presidents can't do much this might
be the truest thing that joe biden's
ever said joe biden can't do much at all
he's given no direction what we know
because of the propaganda that's flooded
everywhere we all we really know about
the ukraine conflict
is ukraine good russia bad
change your facebook profile picture to
be the ukraine flag that's going to help
that's going to be really helpful
and you know tweet about it
you got to tweet about it that's very
important
and um
and maybe make videos uh involving slam
poetry about how vladimir putin has
mommy issues so that'll that'll show him
that'll stop the war
and uh uh beyond that uh
beyond that ooh uh who beats me
this reminds me of when michelle obama
during the obama administration uh was
responding to the boko haram crisis in
africa boko haram this terror group had
gone in and captured a bunch of
extremely young girls and brought them
into sex slavery and the obama
administration's really forceful
response there was to have michelle hold
up a white sheet of paper that said
bring back our girls
and i remember you remember when the
head of boko haram just broke down
crying he said please no more no no more
hashtags michelle we can't take it okay
you can take back your girls take them
take them back michelle please no more
white sheets of paper and memes we can't
take the memes i think no that's not
what happened at all
it's not what happened at all it's
completely completely incoherent
and this is what got donald trump in
trouble
because he made a comment over the
weekend at cpac that got him it was a
true comment that got him in trouble
this is what i thought about when i made
my tweet about how
this is the first major war between
civilized nations in my lifetime and
everyone got angry i thought they didn't
get angry because it's false
no people don't generally get angry at
false statements they just kind of
ignore them or they laugh at them they
get really angry when you make true
statements that political correctness
says you're not allowed to make and
that's what donald trump did over the
weekend at cpac the daily wire
is constantly adding quality content for
your listening and viewing pleasure and
our newest show crane and company is no
exception craning company is a daily
sports show hosted by former athletes
and coaches
jake crane
blaine crane and david cohn
they are joining forces with the daily
wire to bring you all of the sports that
you love with none of the woke nonsense
attached when you tune into crane and
company you will be getting in-depth
sports analysis informative interviews
predictions and wagers and constant live
chat engagement with fans tune in live
today at 3 p.m eastern every weekday
at dailywire.com or on youtube you can
also listen as a podcast on apple
podcast or your platform of choice
make sure you subscribe give the show
five stars if you like what you hear
we'll be right back with a lot more
vladimir putin is a very smart man
the western leaders by and large are
very stupid men
i'm not i'm not making a value judgment
i'm not i'm not ascertaining or
comparing the character the virtues of
these world i'm just
making an obvious observation vladimir
putin is smarter than western leaders
donald trump made that observation
at cpac
and it got him into a whole lot of hot
water
yesterday reporters asked me if i
thought president putin was smart
i said
of course he's smart to which i was
greeted with oh that's such a terrible
thing to say
i'd like to tell the truth yes he's
smart
the nato nations and indeed the world
as he
looks over what's happening
strategically
with no repercussions or threats
whatsoever they're not so smart
they're looking the opposite of smart if
you take over ukraine
we're going to sanction you they say
sanction well that's a pretty weak
statement
putin is saying oh they're going to
sanction me they sanctioned me for the
last 25 years you mean i can take over a
whole country and they're going to
sanction me
you mean they're not going to blow us to
pieces at least
psychologically
the problem
is not that putin is smart
which of course he's smart but the
real problem is that our leaders are
dumb
100
correct
it's funny that people accuse donald
trump of being prideful haughty
irresponsible reckless boastful
he's demonstrating a great deal of
wisdom and humility in this statement
wisdom and humility that our current
leaders don't have
ironically it's our current leaders joe
biden not the least of them who are
demonstrating the haughtiness the
recklessness the irresponsibility
in underestimating vladimir putin
ukraine is in this situation today
because western leaders for a long time
but mostly democrats and especially joe
biden
underestimated vladimir putin donald
trump is giving the devil is due he's
saying no look this guy he's clever he's
smart he's going to
pursue what he feels to be in the
national interest of russia
he's got cojones gotta you gotta give
him that he's got cajones he's not
he's going to call nato's bluff he's
gonna call the american bluff and we're
not gonna do anything about it we're not
even gonna institute real sanctions
we're gonna we're gonna put little fake
sanctions on russia that won't do a damn
thing to to
to really gut their economy if you
really wanted to get their economy you
could put much stiffer sanctions
obviously on the energy industry on
specific oligarchs who are holding
vladimir putin's money but they're not
they're not exactly doing that at least
not yet
our
leaders
are dumb
they're they're so dumb that our leaders
are so dumb they are making the best
argument to support putin
i don't think putin is making a very
good argument to support putin putin is
a sort of cartoonishly villainous figure
and he's now invading this country and
the war is obviously being brought by
him i don't think it's very complicated
as to who is bringing this war
and yet western leaders are so stupid
that they that they have to clutch
defeat from the jaws of victory even on
the publicity front why would anyone
why would anyone support vladimir putin
in this war
richard moore the head of mi6 the
british spy agency he actually gave us
an answer he gave people a reason he
tweeted out over the weekend quote
with with the tragedy and destruction
unfolding so distressingly in ukraine we
should remember the values and hard-won
freedoms that distinguish us from putin
none more
than
lgbt plus rights
so let's resume our series of tweets
to mark
l-g-b-t-h-m is that history month i
thought that was october and whatever
2022
if the only thing
if the main thing
that distinguishes us from vladimir
putin is that we trans the kids
pass the vodka man that's it that are
you kidding me you're gonna have half of
this country go sign up for the red army
if that's the thing that distinguishes
it
transgenderism is what distinguishes us
from putin
that's the best you've got oh my gosh
these people
this it makes me feel a little bit
better actually
i'm sometimes tempted to believe that
the world is actually run by just a
secret cabal of the intelligence
agencies there's a fair bit of evidence
to that effect you know the cia and mi6
and and the the thing that makes me
believe that isn't true is how stupid
the heads of these intelligence agencies
are
it's it's like this guy is putin's
publicist
let's find
one of the worst things that the west is
doing you know transiting the kids
one of the worst things we've ever done
frankly we're mutilating little kids
because of a false anthropology and
convincing little boys that they're
little girls and and we're going to say
that that is the the very best thing
that we're doing and the only thing or
the chief thing that distinguishes us
from our enemies
yeah that'll do it
good you're gonna have people turning in
their ar-15s for kalashnikovs good grief
good grief speaking of british
propaganda
this is a story from last week i didn't
get to it but we had it actually fits in
much better with what we're talking
about today
the queen has coveted
this is a very sad thing
i love the queen she's a very nice
german lady she is one of the last
sensible distinguished noble people in
europe or greater europe britain and
she's one of the last vestiges of of a
government that's not completely insane
in in the west
she's got coven she's very old so i hope
she comes out of
it there was a media report
about her
covid diagnosis
i will describe it as it plays in case
you're listening to this but there's
there's very little
inconvenient fact
that the reporters put into this news
report
people in the 90s are a significant
danger of the bad outcomes of covet
that's true dr makesh haikerwald
patient the queen's age should be
isolating and might benefit from new
medicines currently approved for high
risk
these types of strokes
which is different hold on so so the
first one was just some kind of medicine
go back a little bit hold on a second
stromectol
prescription only three milligrams four
tablets each containing
three milligrams
of ivermectin
oopsie daisy i was i was told that
ivermectin is a horse dewormer
ivor the queen is taking horse dewormer
what man she's dumber than joe rogan
why man that's so crazy does the queen
fight in ufc she must be smoking a lot
of pot too she's probably a crazy alex
jones conspiracy theorist that's weird
in a news report about how the queen at
her advanced age would benefit from some
therapeutics to fight off the the
coronavirus they include ivermectin now
if you try to find that clip right now
you won't succeed
because
the public health establishment got very
upset
the powers that be the sensors got very
upset when it came out and they took the
clip down and the news the news
organization edited it took it out what
they said was this is according to
snopes the network played some b-roll
footage that showed a package of
stromectal a brand-name version of
vibramectin which accidentally
accidentally insinuated that the queen
was using this drug the network has
since apologized and explained that the
footage shown should not have shown soto
sotrov or should have shown rather
social vimab which already did and
improved cover 19 medication not
stromectol
okay so it's not it's not real
don't believe your lying eyes it's all
fake we're sorry the news organization
said we're really really sorry the queen
is definitely not
taking ivermectin you know ivermectin
that very well-known drug
that has been used and prescribed to
humans for many years now
the discoverer of which won the nobel
prize
you know that but that in the last 18
months was just called horsty wormer and
you're not even allowed to prescribe it
anymore yeah do you know that drug that
lots of people who have covet have taken
yeah the queen's totally not taking that
and you you can believe them because
these are the same people who told you
about the ghost of kiev
and the snake island
massacre
and all of the other propaganda that
just is not true at all you you listen
they might have been lying with all of
their other propaganda but this this
time they're totally telling the truth i
would never hey hey youtube censors i
would never insinuate that the queen is
obviously taking ivermectin and that the
news report was right and that now
they're pretending that it was wrong
because of the pressure from you guys i
wouldn't insinuate that
why would i insinuate that
i believe anything that that the ruling
elites tell me
of course
they're always right and they would
never lie to us right
isn't that the case i'm not so sure
there is some good news coming out of
the united kingdom though
uh the good news
is that the uk will be lifting all
remaining coveted restrictions boris
johnson announced quote we will remove
all remaining domestic restrictions in
law from this thursday the 24th of
february we will end the legal
requirement to self-isolate following a
positive test we will end routine
contact racing and no longer ask fully
vaccinated closed contacts and those
under 18 to test daily for seven days we
will remove the legal requirement for
close contacts who are not fully
vaccinated to self-isolate great stuff i
love that that's really good news it's
not just good news coming out of a
nominally conservative but actually
effectively pretty liberal government in
the united kingdom it's coming out of
private corporations woke corporations
super leftist american corporations
google is dropping their vaccine mandate
really really good news google has
announced
they are dropping social distancing
requirements and masks for vaccinated
employees in most areas
they are going to have a few cities that
will still require masks but they're
likely to drop those soon unvaccinated
employees who are approved to enter
offices will still need to follow some
additional protocols
but basically google's going back to
normal you've seen this in lots of
cities around america even left-wing
cities they're dropping the mass
requirements they're dropping the vax
requirements it's over why
why is it over it's over
because
it's election season
it's oh it's not over because kovit's
gone it's not over because we're getting
to covid zero remember that's what the
the libs told us for a while when we get
to zero cases zero transmission that's
when we'll get rid of it no actually
what they originally told us was two
weeks to slow the spread that was two
years ago what day is it
february 28th this all started on march
16th 2020.
we are two weeks away from
two
years of this and they kept moving the
goal posts all the time and it would
slow the spread then flatten the curve
then find a cure then get the jab and
get like three more jabs then you gotta
stop the surge again there was another
surge of the amicron or the delta or the
whatever and it was going to go on
forever and people pushed back and it
killed the ruling class in the polls and
then all of a sudden tooth like magic
the science changed and we get to get
rid of the masks and the vaccine
mandates
why did this happen ties right in with
what we're talking about on the show
today because the people stopped
believing the propaganda
the very concerted propaganda effort
of our ruling class not just the
government but the corporations and the
media and big tech and all of all of it
okay when it gets to something like the
queen
the queen is the queen taking ivermectin
or not i don't know what do i know i
don't know i'm not her doctor i don't
see the queen's prescriptions
it is
it is not necess similar to what i said
at the top of the show it's not
necessarily the case that the queen is
taking ivermectin for her covet
but it is certainly the case that we
have no reason to believe that the queen
is not taking ivermectin
for her govit because we can't
trust these people
this is another thing that's really
really weird about the ukraine russia
war that's different than some of the
other wars that we've had in the last 25
30 years
you've got
nations that are not really united in
any way
say what you will about george bush or
the the wars in the middle east but at
least when we went in
to afghanistan in particular but even
iraq the nation was broadly in favor of
it almost all of the democrats voted for
the iraq war and the republicans were
pushing the iraq war the new york times
was pushing the iraq war right everyone
was kind of in on it now
we are much less united than we were
we don't really trust
our
institutions
we don't trust our elections that we do
the republicans don't believe in the
2020 election in large part the
democrats don't believe in the 2016
election the democrats don't even really
believe in the 2000 election
we're not united so the war is a little
difficult to process
there's a
there's a caveat here to to the way that
we're trying to understand the ukraine
russia war i think that there are some
people on the right in the united states
who are
tempted
to really admire vladimir putin i'll
give you the reasons why well trump says
he's smart
right he
is looking after his nation vladimir
putin ain't no citizen of the world
that's for sure vladimir putin is
interested in russia and expanding
russia and there are a lot of americans
who wish that american leaders were much
more interested in defending america's
borders than they are borders around the
world that would be one reason what's
another reason vladimir putin's not woke
okay say what you will about the man he
ain't woke okay
vladimir putin has been using state
money to build beautiful
cathedrals in russia he built that
beautiful cathedral just a few years ago
what do what do we build in america we
build drag queen story hour venues what
is russia building big cathedrals that's
something i i understand why some people
might like that sort of thing
there's something though that the
admirers of vladimir putin are missing
which is
vladimir putin doesn't like us
okay vladimir putin vladimir putin does
not care about cultural battles in the
united states
he's not on the side of conservatives
he's not rooting for us to win
it's actually a product of liberalism i
think that we believe that all of our
political battles in the united states
just translate exactly
perfectly to political battles in
ukraine or russia or china or anywhere
else
it's a product of globalism actually
that makes us believe that our political
concerns here in america are exactly can
be perfectly mapped on to what's going
on in russia or eastern europe or asia
or wherever but that's not the case
vladimir putin doesn't care about
american conservatives he doesn't care
about american liberals he doesn't like
america he views america as its
adversary
and he's trying to counter america and
counter nato particularly in these
battlegrounds in eastern europe
the trick for us
is
how do we here in the west
get control back of our own governments
because i don't think that our own
establish i don't think our governments
like us either nobody likes us is the
problem vladimir putin doesn't like us
the ruling class in america and the west
more broadly doesn't like us the ruling
class in the west thinks that we're
neo-nazis thinks that where bull connor
thinks that we're hate filled awful
terrible people who just need to go away
and die and then we need to go die of
covet like that teacher said that
teacher was caught on a hidden camera
said that we played last week
we're just
oprah winfrey said this on television
she said you know some of those
backwards conservative they just need to
die
okay they just need to go die
joe biden said it just a few weeks ago
half the country's awful terror so
nobody's really sticking up for us and
it makes us think well i don't
i don't like biden i don't like my
ruling class so am i supposed to no i
don't really like putin i don't know
anything about ukraine i don't
you know socrates
was was one of the smartest men in the
history of the world because he knew
that he knew nothing i think that is
what is required now when we're talking
about this ukraine issue reading a a
think piece on it and and following the
twitter trends and watching videos
supposedly about the coast of kiev does
not make you an expert
on ukrainian policy now i'm preaching to
the choir in a way here i think that
generally the conservatives the more
independent-minded people even in the
center and independent-minded liberals
they know all this okay you guys know
all of this
but the mindless automatons who are just
taking all the propaganda that they are
fed they do not know they do not know
all of this at all
and
it can really lead to some pretty
disastrous results i'll give you just
one anecdote of this in california
a woman tried to get on a bus public bus
she wanted to get on the bus she was
turned away from the bus because she
didn't have a mask on
she then was run over by the bus
but at least she didn't get covered
she was run over tragically killed
lucy prieto frescus 15 59 years old a
young woman
tried to get on the bus
turned away
somehow she fell underneath the bus and
was run over this is the perfect analogy
for our kovid regime
people driven crazy by absurd propaganda
forced into their heads for two years
straight
are now doing much more harm than good
the lockdown measures have always been
doing more harm than good some of us
called this two years ago
but that's certain it's certainly the
case now
we in the west what we have done
out of fear of
a cold out of fear of a cough
have thrown our citizens literally under
the bus it's sad that this real life
tragedy is such a good analogy but it is
speaking of california
there are some signs that things are
improving at least on the right
kevin mccarthy is the house minority
leader he's the republican leader in the
house of representatives kevin mccarthy
just threw his former colleague liz
cheney under the bus liz cheney was in
republican leadership can you imagine
that it shows you how bad off the
republican party is liz cheney was in
republican leadership
and
she spent all of her time going on cnn
talking to the washington post attacking
republicans and conservatives now kevin
mccarthy her leader has
endorsed her primary challenger a
harriet hageman
that's good that's a good sign
the people who like liz cheney are
democrats exclusively
and so from a tactical standpoint
even for maybe the moderates or the
independents or whatever who who are
they're kind of more liberal but maybe
they'd consider voting for you saying
maybe okay maybe we should go with
liz cheney right lis maybe she can
appeal to more people because she's more
in the middle
even more a little bit on the left
she won't appeal to more people she'll
appeal to nobody
that is propaganda
liz cheney appeals to people
who will never vote for a republican
she is the republican where democrats
say you know i could vote for that kind
of republican but they
maybe they could but they wouldn't they
would always choose the democrat over
her
we have been fed this kind of propaganda
we on the right in america
for decades well you better nominate
john mccain because democrats could vote
for that kind of republican yeah they
could but they won't
yeah you should vote for mitt romney you
should nominate mitt romney democrats
could vote for that republican except
they won't except they won't do it
okay there has been there is a huge
amount of waking up there's a little bit
of a paradox we live in an age where
propaganda is so easy to produce and
it's so easy to produce at a very high
level
that actually i think a lot of people
are waking up to it they're seeing
through it they're saying wait a second
if i can't even believe a video that i'm
watching because it was likely
manipulated what can i believe
we are headed for a very very messy
period politically internationally
you're already seeing that happen
domestically you're seeing that happen
too the only way out is through do not
believe everything you see on the
internet i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you
[Music]
tomorrow the michael knowles show is
produced by ben davies executive
producer jeremy boring our technical
director is austin stevens supervising
producer mathis glover production
manager pavel vadovsky editor and
associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show vladimir
putin surrounds keeb and puts his
nuclear forces on high alert as europe
moves to isolate him we'll bring you all
the latest that's today on the bench
spiro shall give it a listen